[Applaus]
ja meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
liebe parteifreunde geschätzte
anwesenden pressevertreter verehrte
weiterer gäste es ist also mal wieder
afd parteitag und es finden mal wieder
die üblichen spielchen statt
draußen vor der halle tobt ein zu nicht
geringen teilen gewaltbereiter mob der
diesmal gar keine mühen gescheut hat
sogar speziell zu unserem
bundesparteitag 1 44 seitigen
reiseführer für krawall touristen heraus
zu geben mit vielen freundlichen
insider-tipps der sogenannten anti
faschisten wie man unseren parteitag am
besten wörtlich angreifen kann inklusive
nützliche hinweise wie man am besten
fassaden beutelt verunziert mit
farbbeuteln jemand autos anzündet wie
man wurfgeschosse bastelt und
wirkungsvoll einsetzt und vielen anderen
kostbaren hinweisen mehr deutschland im
sommer 2018 ein halbes jahrhundert nach
zielsetzung dieser von spd linken grünen
und dgb nachgebesserten
linksterroristischen dumpfbacken und
und fdp wollen die das fürchten lehren
und idealerweise unseren parteitag
stören darf oder dafür sorgen dass der
gar nicht stattfinden kann
ich sags mal so und man sieht es ja das
wird nix wir lassen uns von dieser
antifa kavallerie nicht einschüchtern
und wir ziehen unser ding durch gegen
alle widerstände wie wir das seit jahren
gewöhnt sind liebe freunde nichts
anderes wie richtig wir liegen und wie
wichtig und notwendig für unser land wir
sind zeigt nicht zuletzt gerade diese
antifaschist die sogenannten mit ihren
gewalttätigen methoden der faschisten
insofern kann man ihnen zurufen habe
dank für eure überzeugungsarbeit für uns
drinnen in der halle haben wir die
medienvertreter auch die treiben ihre
üblichen und einige betone einige auch
ihre üblen spielchen
die liegen natürlich vor allem darin uns
zerstrittenheit und erzwang andichten zu
wollen um uns möglichst als uneinigen
zerstrittenen haufen darstellen zu
können
die stuttgarter nachrichten ich habe
dass die tage gelesen sprechen gar mal
wieder von einer zerreißprobe zum
wievielten mal eigentlich diesmal eine
zerreißprobe vorgeblich zwischen
wirtschaftsliberalen und
nationalkonservativen um nicht
missverstanden zu werden und daran
keinen zweifel zu lassen
das ist legitim ich beklage dass nicht
journalismus hat durchaus die aufgabe
das zu testen und kritisch zu berichten
und zu schauen wo vorher unter dem dach
ist sowieso nur und dafür inzwischen
auch immer mehr vertretern der
schreibenden und senden zunft glasklar
die pressevertreter wenn sie wirklich
tiefe zerstrittenheit zerrissenheit
wechselseitiges misstrauen
programmatische hilflosigkeit und echte
zerreißprobe suchen dann gehen sie doch
zu csu cdu csu da finden sie das in
hülle und fülle nicht bei uns
nahezu täglich wird es laut skurriler
dazu später noch ein paar worte bei uns
auf dem bundesparteitag der afb gibt es
dagegen intensiven diskurs um die besten
lösungen für die zukunft unseres landes
sogar womöglich hier und da mal
lebhaften streit aber nur in der sache
weil die uns am herzen liegt weil wir
aufrecht ich die besten lösungen für
deutschland und seine menschen suchen in
der sozialpolitik in der
migrationspolitik in der energiepolitik
in der finanzpolitik in der
bildungspolitik überall
und weil es dazu unterschiedliche
lösungsansätze gibt und geben geben darf
gerade bei uns eben weil es bei uns kein
meinungs- diktat gibt von oben und auch
nicht geben soll
da sind wir anders als die anderen da
wird das von oben korrigiert das gibt es
bei uns in alternative für deutschland
nicht auch darin sind wir alternative
feierte verehrte pressevertreter seien
sie uns also herzlich willkommen sie
befinden sich bei der einzigen
alternative für deutschland
berichten sie kritisch aber fair was ich
hierzu trägt werden sie ihrer
chronistenpflicht gerecht informieren
sie über das geschehen auf diesem
parteitag ein thema das mit recht
schon vor diesem parteitag recht großes
interesse gefunden hat und auch bereits
so manche wände geschlagen hat ist die
bislang noch unvollendete programmatik
unserer jungen partei in fragen der
sozialpolitik speziell der rentenpolitik
und ja das stimmt wir sind da noch nicht
fertig und schilde zunächst einmal fest
dass darf sein und das darf auch nach
diesem parteitag noch so sein
das muss sogar nach diesem parteitag
noch so seien gerade in diesem zugleich
hochsensiblen und hochkomplexen bereich
geht gründlichkeit und tiefe vor
schnelligkeit und wir lassen uns da
nicht treiben
wir müssen dazu wir müssen dazu klar und
verbindlich aufgestellt sein
wenn wir eines tages in
regierungsverantwortung gehen und dieser
tag wird kommen liebe freunde
es ist aber absurd uns hier eine offene
flanke vorzuwerfen
die vor allem die altparteien die mehr
oder weniger lange hier seit etlichen
jahren regieren selbst ganz offenkundig
haben denn nicht eine nicht eine dieser
etablierten altparteien nicht eine hat
ein glaubhaftes und tragfähiges konzept
zur rentenpolitik
es gibt kein konzept der altparteien es
gibt kein konzept der altparteien dem
die zwangs beitragszahler in die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung mit dem
sie auch nur halbwegs zufrieden sein
könnten alle diese parteien liebe
freunde gibt es seit jahrzehnten
einige von ihnen haben rentenpolitik in
all den jahren aktiv gestaltet und keine
von ihnen liefert eine überzeugende
antwort auf die probleme die in den
nächsten drei jahrzehnten vor uns liegen
und die rufen nun die afg hat ja kein
konzept mit verlaub wir arbeiten daran
und zwar auf einem niveau dass diese
parteien in jahrzehnten offenkundig
nicht erreicht haben oder es schlicht
verpennt haben
gucken sie sich puppen sich waren was
die cdu dazu hat die kommen noch heute
20 jahre nach norbert blüm über dessen
die rente ist sicher nicht mehr hinaus
das galt übrigens durchaus seine rente
aber für einige andere renten schon
damals nicht mehr diese parteien mögen
sich also allesamt mal an die eigene
nase packen bevor sie auf uns eine
gerade einmal fünf jahre alte partei mit
einem finger weisen während vier finger
auf sie selbst zurück weisen liebe
freunde ihm die massive renten
problematik in deutschland hat nun ganz
gewiss nicht die alternative für
deutschland zu verantworten sondern die
ist resultat jahrzehntelanger
verschleppung der altparteien auszeiten
kommend als die afd
noch nicht einmal als gedanke existierte
das wird wohl niemand ernsthaft
bestreiten wollen es sind diese parteien
die zu verantworten haben
denn rentner heute pfandflaschen aus
müllcontainern sammeln müssen um
halbwegs über die runden zu kommen
das haben die zu verantworten diese
parteien sind wohl die letzten die
oberlehrerhaft mit dem moralischen
zeigefinger auf und weisen dürfen nun
wäre es freilich unserer seite billig
wenn wir es den gleichen und auf deren
versagen hinwiesen ohne selbst
lösungsansatz mit substanz zu liefern
und darum arbeiten wir daran und zwar
seit geraumer zeit und in jüngster zeit
sehr intensiv und dabei kommen auch
ergebnisse heraus bei uns soll nämlich
leute in unseren reihen haben die von
der materie etwas verstehen und die nun
erste ausgearbeitete lösungsansätze
liefern
da gibt es diverse diskussionsbeiträge
und arbeitspapiere die auch schon
öffentlich vorgestellt wurden
die kann man teil und für gut befinden
zur gänze oder in teilen wiederum oder
die kann man auch für weniger
zielführend halten je nach eigenen
denken dazu nur eines da sage ich hier
ganz klar nur eines kann man ganz
bestimmt nicht nämlich sie gering
schätzen weil man anderer meinung ist
hier haben etliche mit aber mehr
mitglieder nachgedacht gerechnet
gearbeitet sich die mühe gemacht ganz
mehr mehrheitlich ehrenamtlich übrigens
eine konzeption zu entwickeln
und manche auch komplett durch zu
rechnen was kein pappenstiel ist sondern
richtig viel arbeit das ist zunächst
einmal in hohem maße wertzuschätzen
liebe freunde und es ist übrigens auch
nicht zu beklagen wie es manche tun das
es gleich mehrere diskussionsbeiträge
gibt sondern das ist erfreulich auch
wenn sie zu teilen unterschiedlichen
ansätzen folgen
das sind allesamt substanzielle beiträge
zur innerparteilichen meinungsbildung
und zur späteren finalen positionierung
zum thema und ich sage zur späteren
finalen positionierung von meiner seite
darum zunächst einmal die dies gemacht
haben habe dank für arbeit das verdienst
für die partei das ist guter dienst für
unser land das noch immer von einer
konzeptions- und visionslos
soldo elite gesteuert wird die sich
wieder und wieder zu langfristigem
denken völlig unfähig erweisen
und nun schreiben einige medienvertreter
waren gar nicht so wenige insbesondere
mir müssten diese beiträge aber doch
inhaltlich geradezu die zornesröte ins
gesicht treiben
denn sie trügen sehr deutlich starts
paternalistische züge und das müsse mich
als ausgewiesenen wirtschaftsliberalen
doch geradezu auf die palme bringen
dazu möchte ich mich etwas eingehende
äußern
denn das erscheint mir hier notwendig
zunächst soll ist für mich auch da keine
kategorie
ich bin denen die da ihre
arbeitsergebnisse abliefern ich hab's ja
gesagt hochgradig dankbar dafür
dies auch dann wenn ich inhaltlich
teilweise tatsächlicher an tatsächlich
anderer auffassung bin
und ja das bin ich durchaus wenn es um
fragen der zukunft der altersvorsorge in
unserem land geht
ich halte es für zurückhaltend
formuliert einigermaßen sorglos einem
staat der das migrations chaos
angerichtet hat der auch das euro
desaster zu verantworten hat der eine
energiewende gegen alle vernunft auf den
weg gebracht hat und durchzieht
tatsächlich die nahezu komplette
altersvorsorge seiner bürger
anzuvertrauen
nein mein misstrauen gegenüber
staatlichen lösungen ist sicherlich und
aus vielerlei guten gründen deutlich
höher als das mancher autoren dieser
arbeitspapiere
das hat damit zu tun dass ich als
finanzwissenschaftler mit fragen der
öffentlichen haushalte durch steuern
beiträge und sonstige abgaben seit drei
jahrzehnten massiv befasst war
und wenn man das tut dann gelangt man
geradezu zwangsläufig zu diesem
misstrauen gegenüber praktizierter
sozialpolitik wie wir sie kennen meine
damen und herren der bestehende
sozialstaat wie wir ihn haben ist nicht
sozial
er ist in seinen ergebnissen zu weiten
teilen geradezu asozial
das ist das was wir haben und das ist
das problem
der vorgebliche sozialstaat zerstört
durch enorme abgabe belasten in form von
steuern und sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
die nahezu keinem land es gibt nur ganz
wenige ausnahmen so hoch sind wie bei
uns in deutschland gesellschaftlich
extrem wichtige soziale klein verbünde
wie funktionierende familien die unter
diesen lasten nicht selten in die knie
gehen hängt stattdessen menschen wie
junkies an die nadel eines
vermeintlichen sozialstaats der mit all
den hunderten milliarden die das sind
pro jahr nicht im entferntesten das
leistet das doch die eigentliche aufgabe
eines tragfähigen echten sozialstaates
wäre nämlich subsidiäre hilfe für die
menschen in wirklicher not die aus den
unterschiedlichsten gründen und
lebensläufen ihr dasein tatsächlich
nicht ohne hilfestellung bewältigt
bekommen
die fühlen sich verraten verkauft und
allein gelassen und liebe freunde da
liegen sie keineswegs falsch
unser staat mehr stattdessen unter
anderem eine fette und verfettete sozial
industrie mit einer geradezu krankhaften
verwahre krakenhaften verwaltung
krakenhaften wird um nachsicht die
gerade im bereich der rentenversicherung
möglichst viele in das system hinein
zwingen will
die das aus guten gründen keineswegs
wollen liebe freunde wir dürfen wenn wir
unserem anspruch eine wirkliche
alternative für deutschland zu sein
gerecht werden wollen nicht diesen weg
den bereits ausnahmslos alle anderen
parteien beschreiten ebenfalls betreten
das heißt nun keineswegs und das ist mir
wichtig das zu betonen wie uns linke
ideologen geflissentlich unter stellen
werden künftig keine sozialpolitik mehr
zu machen und die menschen sich einfach
allesamt selbst zu überlassen
um es ganz klar zu sagen wir sind als
afd keine neoliberale keine wolke wohl
der kapitalistische partei und das
werden wir auch nicht sein
gehen wir dem irrweg der bislang
praktizierten sozialpolitik dort wo sie
falsch und verlogen ist eine absage
erteilen das ist kein neoliberalismus
liebe freunde sondern sondern ist es uns
aufgetragen eine wirklich soziale
sozialpolitik an den tag zu legen eine
politik die den sorgen und nöten des
vielzitierten kleinen mannes des ganz
normalen arbeitnehmers tatsächlich
gerecht wird anstatt ihn mit steuern und
abgaben auszubeuten und ihnen so dann
vermeintlich großzügige staatliche
almosen zu teil werden zu lassen
das ist das was passiert unentwegt
passiert dass kein mensch redet in
diesem land darüber die
grunderwerbsteuer abzuschaffen
stattdessen reden wir von baukindergeld
der ist genau das nehmen dann sehen sie
sich das an was sie daraus machen
das ist lächerlich liebe freunde
tatsächlich tatsächlich brauchen wir
diese ideologie nicht wir brauchen weder
eine sozialistische noch eine
neoliberale sozialpolitik sondern eine
die kluge wegweisung der sozialen
marktwirtschaft wieder aufgreift und
sich ein elementarer vernunft statt an
dieser oder jener ideologie orientiert
liebe freunde
es geht um eine zielgerichtete auf die
bedürfnisse der wirklich schwachen
ausgerichtete sozialpolitik in unserem
land das haben wir derzeit nicht hören
wir also auf diese und schellen
umgehängten klischees von sozial
paternalistisch links auf der einen
seite und neoliberal rechts auf der
anderen seite zu glauben und womöglich
sie auch noch zu übernehmen
fragen wir uns lieber mal was schlicht
fakt ist gerade in der politik der
altersvorsorge mit dessen zukunft wir
uns intensiv befassen
fakt ist dass der sogenannte kleine mann
der einfache arbeitnehmer mit einem ganz
normalen durchschnittseinkommen in
diesem land und hier verzeihen sie mir
bitte die ausnahmsweise derbe wortwahl
verarscht wird verabschiedet nach strich
und faden und bis zum gehtnichtmehr
und zwar gerade von jenen linken die
vorgeben sich für sein wohlergehen und
seine interessen einzusetzen ihm aber in
ihrer kleptokraten noch das letzte hemd
nimmt das ist perfide was die machen die
meisten in die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung einzahlen den
menschen und das sind in diesem land
37,6 millionen menschen dürfen da
dürften davon ausgehen dass sie als
einzahlung in das system ihren
arbeitnehmerbeitrag entrichten und dafür
später als auszahlung eben ihre
altersrente beziehen und es wird ihnen
suggeriert damit erhielten sie eine gute
versorgung die der staat durch das
rentenversicherungssystem ihnen bietet
liebe freunde daran ist so gut wie alles
falsch de facto zahlt ein arbeitnehmer
monat für monat gleich dreimal in die
rentenversicherung systeme ein
neben seinem ausgewiesenen
arbeitnehmerbeitrag den ja niemand in
zweifel zieht zahlt er natürlich
faktisch auch den arbeitgeberbeitrag
denn gäbe es diesen nicht wehren
logischerweise die löhne auf seine
arbeitsleistung auf die ja der
arbeitgeberanteil entrichtet wird
entsprechend höher also trägt auch
diesen teil de facto der arbeitnehmer
nämlich durch entsprechenden
lohnverzicht weiß jeder der sich mit der
materie jemand etwas eingehender befasst
hat da zahlt das schon zweimal
doch damit keineswegs genug er zahlt ein
drittes mal
es kommt hinzu dass er mit weitem
abstand größte posten im bundeshaushalt
und das wissen nicht mehr alle die
bezuschussung des bundes an die
rentenversicherung ist gut 98 milliarden
euro das sind rund 30 prozent des
gesamten bundeshaushaltes werden
benötigt um alle ausgaben des
rentenversicherungssystem leisten zu
können sonst werde das system schon
lange zusammen gebrochen
das heißt im klartext der arbeitnehmer
zahlt natürlich auch noch mit seiner
entrichteten lohnsteuer in das
rentenversicherungssystem ein und das
eine dritte einzahlung und von dem geld
das ihm dann noch im geldbeutel
verbleibt zahlt er immer noch weiter ein
mit jedem einkauf im supermarkt oder im
baumarkt mit jeder befüllung seines
autos mit benzin an der tankstelle
bedient er die laufenden auszahlungen
aus der rentenversicherung und zwar
nicht mit cracker beiträgen einmal
beispielhaft um es ein bisschen zu
illustrieren verdient
ein arbeitnehmer 3000 euro brutto zahlt
der aktuell 280 euro arbeitnehmeranteil
die grv 1
hinzu kommen weitere 280 euro
arbeitgeberanteil die aber natürlich
lohnbestandteil sind macht zusammen
bereits 560 euro entrichtet darüber
hinaus aber auch 425 euro lohnsteuer von
diesen fließen weitere 54 euro in den
bundeszuschuss zur rentenversicherung
den anteil aus dem sogenannten
solidaritätszuschlag auf dass eine
einzige mogelpackung noch nicht
mitgerechnet bereits damit entrichtet er
und 612 euro monatlichen herz bestehende
rentenversicherungssystem bei 3000 euro
brutto kaufte er nun von dem ihm
verbleibende nettoeinkommen güter des
täglichen lebensbedarfs kommen
erkleckliche weitere beträge hinzu
betankt er etwa sein auto an einer
tankstelle mit 40 liter super bei einem
unterstellten benzinpreis 59 zahlt er
ohne es zu merken noch mal weitere fast
zehn euro ins rentensystem ein mit jeder
tankfüllung seines autos fährt er dann
mit dem betankten auto zum baumarkt und
er steht dort waren zum nettopreis 150
euro sind die nächsten fünf euro ins
rentensystem fällig im supermarkt geht
es dann weiter
alles zur freude des finanzministers
hilft unmerklich nur mit akribischer
führung eines haushalts muss und
tieferer kenntnis der steuerverteilung
auf die gebietskörperschaften ebenen und
liebe freunde wäre hätte die schon
könnte der deutsche michel die
tatsächliche vollständige summe all
seine einzahlungen in das rentensystem
ermitteln was er ganz gewiss nicht tut
er geht stattdessen regelhaft davon aus
seinen arbeitnehmerbeitrag von dem
kleinen beispiel 280 euro zu entrichten
und das war's dann
und er hofft nun daraus eine spätere
rentenzahlung mit einer fairen kleinen
verzinsung mindestens jedoch bei
durchschnittlicher lebenserwartung einer
rückzahlung seiner geleisteten
einzahlungen die bekommt er aber nicht
es ist ein lausick schlechtes geschäft
was er da macht nicht zufällig werden
all die diskussionen um das garantierte
sicherungsniveau geführt dennoch nur die
sicherung des bestehenden bereits sehr
niedrigen rentensystem 47,5 prozent
führt bis zum jahr 2000
20 zu ausgabensteigerungen die innerhalb
des bestehenden systems nicht zu
halbwegs akzeptable belastung der
beitragszahler aufgefangen werden können
von höheren leistungsniveaus wir den
gerne angestrebten 50 prozent ganz zu
schweigen
schon heute bekommt der vielzitierte
eckrentner nach hypothetischen 45
beitragsjahren auf basis des
medianeinkommens also des
durchschnittseinkommens gerade einmal
eine bruttorente von 1370 euro
vor abzug von elf prozent sozialabgaben
jener noch ab es liegt dann natürlich
auf der hand dass millionen menschen
übrigens gerade im osten unseres landes
die weder dieses durchschnittseinkommen
im erwerbsleben erzielt haben noch ist
auf die vollen 45 beitragsjahre bringen
weil sie unterbrochene erwerbsbiografien
haben heute längst eher die regel wie
die heute längst eher die regel denn die
ausnahme sind das die erheblich unter
diesem bereits sehr kritischen
rentenniveau des centers liegen und den
nicht geringer zahl auf rentenhöhen
kommen die die jedem gewährte
grundsicherung im alter nicht oder
allenfalls marginal überschreiten
mit vollem recht fragen sich nun diese
menschen die auch viele jahrzehnte und
oft alles andere als einfachen
bedingungen geschuftet und in das system
eingezahlt haben
ob die beklagenswert geringe differenz
zur grundsicherung wenn sie die
überhaupt erreichen ihre
jahrzehntelangen beiträge dann
rechtfertigt
alles was recht ist aber wer derlei
sozial gerecht nennt ist entweder nicht
mehr ganz bei trost kann nicht rechnen
oder aber erst ausgesprochen zynisch
liebe freunde
und wer glaubt wer glaubt diese
problematik ließe sich durch das drehen
einer etwas stellschrauben oder
zwangsweise einbeziehung weiterer
beitragszahler gruppen gegen deren
willen natürlich bei verbleib innerhalb
des bestehenden systems der
umlagefinanzierten rentenversicherungen
lösen
meine damen und herren dem widerspreche
ich entschieden das derzeitige das ist
der harte forderung das derzeitige
umlage basierte beitragssystem
suggeriert also eine
beitragsgerechtigkeit die es nicht gibt
und die zukunft schon gar nicht mehr
geben wird
sie muss nicht zufällig auf ein mit
zwangssystem öffentlich-rechtlicher
beiträge betrieben werden weil die
menschen sonst dem system in scharen
fliehen würden um ihre geschicke selbst
in die hand zu nehmen
das aber genau das lässt der staat nicht
zu und nennt das sozial und das löst man
nicht dadurch die anderen die dieses
nicht zukunftsfähige und nicht mehr
zeitgemäße system noch nicht einzahlen
müssen nun auch noch zwangsweise
integriert es ist nicht klug ein krankes
system immer weiter messen zu wollen
liebe freunde
damit damit schafft man letztlich nur
eine sozialistische lösung nach dem
modell der bürgerversicherung das wollen
hier in unserem land und die linken das
wollen die grünen die sozialdemokraten
und weite teile der union auch wir
sollten diesen weg nun nicht ebenfalls
auch noch anhängen
das umlagesystem wird dadurch immer noch
nicht gerecht es wird immer noch nicht
dem äquivalenz gedanken jetzt sprechen
der den beitrags- denken zugrunde liegt
und effizient wird es schon gar nicht
sein
was also sollte stattdessen getan werden
wenn er wenn wir eine wirkungsvolle und
zugleich sozial gerechte zukunftsfähige
lösung haben wollen ich bin mir sicher
es geht nur mit einer freiheitlichen
lösung in der wir zwei dinge tun müssen
erstens müssen wir die menschen schritt
für schritt in eine selbst gewählte
freie form ihrer altersvorsorge
entlassen das muss nicht zwingend
kapitalgedecktes sparen sein da gibt es
sehr viele möglichkeiten
wer beklagt das gelingen doch kaum jedem
perfekt der vergleiche bitte mit den
eklatanten schwächen des bestehenden
systems und vorurteile für sich wohl die
größeren schwächen liegen
ich behaupte nicht dass das die perfekte
lösung ist weil es die nicht gibt aber
es ist allemal die weniger schlechte
lösung der die die wir haben ist die
schlechteste von allen
für die die das aufgrund bestehender
individuelle handicaps nicht schaffen
kommt in wahrung seiner sozialen
funktionen der staat in seiner funktion
als sozialstaat auf und zwar wenn wir
gerecht sein wollen aus allgemeinen
steuermitteln
denn dies ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe und
nicht die aufgabe einer gruppe von
zwangs beitragszahler liebe freunde
zweitens zweitens und das gehört
zwingend dazu müssen wir diesen
systemwechsel weg vom zwangs
finanzierten umlagesystem zwingend mit
einigen fundamentalen veränderungen
unseres steuersystems begleichen denn
die lösung kann nun keinesfalls darin
bestehen ich glaube das leuchtet auf
jedem sofort ein
den vielzitierten kleinen man nun eben
nicht mehr ihre beitragszahlung auf
seinen arbeitseinkommen sondern
stattdessen in gleicher höhe wie die
steuerzahlung auf seinen
arbeitseinkommen zugelassen
die steuerfinanzierung darf eben nicht
so aussehen dass sie die gleichen
arbeitnehmer das sie gleichen
arbeitnehmer dann künftig an steuern
entrichten was sie bislang als beiträge
entrichtet haben damit wäre nichts
gewonnen das wäre das hinlänglich
bekanntes spiel eine tasse rein andere
wieder raus und dafür treten wir als
alternative für deutschland nicht an
unser steuersystem genauer unser
gesamtes derzeitiges abgabesystem über
die steuern hinaus krankt an einer
geradezu perversen belastung des
produktionsfaktors arbeit und hier
insbesondere der einfachen gewöhnlichen
nicht selbstständigen
arbeitnehmereinkommen und zwar schlicht
aufgrund der tatsache dass man dort am
einfachsten zugreifen kann und das ist
in höchstem maße ungerecht
währenddessen
während des liebe freunde gibt es eine
große zahl an menschen die ihr leben
ganz vortrefflich und ich kenne einige
von denen von diversen kapitaleinkünften
ohne dabei allzu schmerzhaft wird
staatlichen abgaben belastet zu werden
und so leben wir in einer geradezu
himmelschreiend ungerecht und steuer
welt mit der quasi eine
klassengesellschaft immer weiter
zementiert wird
während die einen arbeiten und arbeiten
und arbeiten und doch nicht zuletzt
aufgrund der abgabenlast niemals einen
grünen zweig kommen fahren andere wie
woher auch immer gut situierten schon
mittags mit ihren schicken luxus cabrio
lewis am golfplatz und widmen sich den
diversen annehmlichkeiten des lebens der
eben besser betuchten so geht das nicht
es kann nicht angehen dass einerseits
millionen von menschen obwohl sie
arbeiten kein geld haben um zum beispiel
in diesem sommer mal für eine woche im
sommer urlaub zu fahren
das können sich nämlich ziemlich viele
nicht leisten während zugleich die
robinson clubs der luxus urlaub bestens
gebucht und besucht sind und legen sehen
wir das nun bitte nicht als linken
klassenkampf aus ich stelle nur fest was
ist so wenig wie ich der eiskalte
neoliberale bin hat mich manchmal ja so
gerne darstellen weil sie ihre
schubladen brauchen so wenig bin ich
auch linker klassenkämpfer darum geht es
mir nicht
ich bin ein verfechter sozialer
marktwirtschaft auch in der
altersvorsorge durch und durch und ich
habe mir ein untrügliches gefühl für
ungerechtigkeit bewahrt dass ich schon
zu kindertagen entwickelt habe ich hatte
eine kindheit in essen holsterhausen
damals einem arbeiterviertel bei
schulbesuchen essen bredeney dem
reichsten viertel der ansonsten nicht
mit reichtum gesegneten stadt das prägt
meine damen und herren wir brauchen ein
steuersystem das einfache arbeit
deutlich entlastet und kapitaleinkünfte
und ich betone luxus konsum deutlich
stärker belastet
dafür sollten wir uns einsetzen
parallel zur skizzierten umstellung der
altersvorsorge weg vom beitragssystem
hin zur regelhaft privaten
altersvorsorge das liebe freunde ist die
richtung die ich mir wünsche für unser
land die für die programmatik unserer
partei das ist freiheitlich und sozial
zugleich und das ist unsere aufgabe
diese beiden punkte miteinander zu
vereinen
denn das ist das wofür wir stehen wir
sind in der tat soziale bürgerpartei und
wir sind zugleich freiheitliche bürger
partei und das muss man sinnvoll unter
einen hut bringen und so geht das den
müssen dann als gesamte abgabesystem ran
sonst wird das nichts
und da muss man sich zeit für nehmen
mögen die medienvertreter nun also
rätseln welches etikett wie mir dieser
richtung künftig anheften neoliberal ist
das gewiss nicht links und starts war
terroristisch ist es auch nicht kleiner
tipp vielleicht mal wieder peheim rob
gelesen einem großen deutschen den die
nazis damals wegen seiner gegenwehr
gegen deren aufkommen bereits exil
getrieben haben da können sie lesen wo
was herkommt liebe parteifreunde
diese sozialpolitische thema ist von
großer wichtigkeit
und auch das aufgreifen was wir eben an
diskussion hat meine tagesordnung des
debatte wir werden uns hier die zeit
nehmen die wir brauchen um unsere
sorgsam abgestimmte konzeption fertig zu
entwickeln ist beschlussreife hat und
dann auf einem parteitag beschlossen
werden kann
ich begrüße wegen der wichtigkeit dieses
themas ausdrücklich den vorschlag dazu
zum geeigneten zeitpunkt einen
schwerpunkt parteitag abzuhalten
das wird der bedeutung dieses themas
gerecht und genauso sollten wir das auch
machen
ich kann dass wir dann im saal
vermutlich jeder verstehen meine
ausführungen dazu nicht schließen ohne
das thema zugleich einen noch größeren
kontext der aktuellen lage unseres
landes zu stellen
der natürlich liegt die frage nahe was
wird uns denn die beste sozialrentner
und steuerpolitische konzeption noch
nutzen wenn unser land durch die
desaströse politik der bundeskanzlerin
und ihrer dilettantischen entourage in
ihrem multikulturalisten waren immer
weiter zu grunde gerichtet wird machen
wir uns das mal klar wir leben
inzwischen in einem land in dem ein
innenminister der versucht geltendes
recht durchzusetzen indem er menschen
die ein einreiseverbot haben die
einreise auch wirklich verbieten und das
verbot einer grenze endlich durchsetzen
möchte dafür in einen heftigen disput
mit der regierungschefin gerät die
bereits damit nicht einverstanden ist
und er überdies auf vollständiges
unverständnis für die einhaltung
geltenden rechts beim koalitionspartner
spd trifft derlei mag vielleicht in
einer bananenrepublik nicht weiter
erstaunlich sein aber das hier liebe
freunde dass es deutschland deutschland
ist eigentlich ein zivilisierter
rechtsstaat und keine bananenrepublik
der innenminister forderte die
durchsetzung geltenden rechts sind die
bundeskanzlerin wieder koalitionspartner
machen da nicht mit
stattdessen werden wir durch eine
politik der de facto nach wie vor
offenen grenzen
geradezu systematisch in genau jeden
kampf der kulturen oder im englischen
original clash of civilizations
hineingetrieben der c moll huntington
schon vor mehr als 20 jahren angekündigt
hat wieder einmal liegt eine verquere
ideologie den zu grunde
es ist die vorstellung des
multikulturalismus die viele politisch
völlig naive menschen vor allem im
wohlstands verwöhnten und dekadent
gewordenen westen europas in die utopie
einer schönen heilen welt ohne grenzen
hinein getrieben hat
viele viel zu viele menschen hängen
dieser no borders ideologie an und sie
werden darin noch bekräftigt und
wichtigen multiplikatoren ich denke da
etwa an die amtskirchen die sich daher
vor tun und natürlich all die politisch
engagierten deren handeln auf den
idealen der links rot-grün verseuchten
68er denke beruht oh ja ich wiederhole
diesen begriff ich werde das noch so
lange und immer wieder tun wie es
notwendig ist die zeitenwende von dieser
denke durchzusetzen
das ist endlich wieder und wieder tun
ich habe neben pressevertretern gefragt
ob ich wieder von links rot-grün
versetzen sprechen wäre gesagt ich mache
das solange solange wir das haben wenn
wir das los und hört auf damit aber noch
ein bisschen arbeit
es sind die sn die diebe oft als
gutmenschen bezeichnen was er nicht
recht zutreffender begriff ist dieses
ganze denken beruht und das ist der
kardinalfehler auf einem rein gesinnungs
ethischen ansatz politik aber muss
verantwortungs ethisch denken und
handeln sonst wird sie unweigerlich ein
desaster
ein desaster dass wir derzeit aus genau
diesem grund erleben und inzwischen
werden immer mehr menschen wach und die
das sehe ich mit freude immer mehr
menschen wach und beginnen zu verstehen
was frau merkel und ihre ganze
multikulti entourage sie angerichtet
haben und immer noch weiter anrichten
leider geht diese saat durchaus immer
noch auf vor einiger zeit ist noch nicht
lange her da ich einige noch sehr jungen
demonstranten am rande einer und einer
unserer veranstaltung nach meiner
einschätzung waren das noch schüler die
ltte ganz beseelt einblick es ein plakat
in die höhe auf dem geschrieben stand
wer in grenzen denkt ist begrenzt im
denken da ist die ideologische
indoktrination in reinster form
aufgegangen diesen jungen menschen und
ich fürchte das sind deutlich mehr als
dieses verlorene häuflein hat offenbar
nie jemand den kulturellen ursprung und
sinn der existenz von nationalstaaten
erklärt das haben die in der schule
schlichtweg mehr gelernt
und es hat ihnen und es hat ihnen auch
niemand gesagt dass staaten auch grenzen
haben müssen um dort bestehen zu können
und warum das nicht von übel sondern
wünschenswert ist nicht zuletzt und
sogar für sie selbst als junger blogger
ihres staates ganz besonders hätte ihnen
das jemand erklärt die frage liegt nahe
wurde er in der schule passiert das
exakte gegenteil dort wird er erklärt
warum wir nur gefährliche partei sind
hätte man ihnen das erklärt so hätten
sie vielleicht an ganz anderer stelle
demonstriert etwa vor einem parteitag
der linken der grünen oder der spd oder
auch vom bundeskanzleramt und sie hätten
dort auch ein ganz anderes plakat in die
höhe hochgehalten auf dem schöne zum
beispiel geschrieben weil wir keine
grenzen haben und keine grenzen setzen
haben wir grenzenlose probleme so ein
paar kann würde ich mir wünschen
denn nur mehr menschen das verstünden
und es so forderten nun durchsetzen
hätten wir weit weniger probleme daran
dieses bewusstsein zu schaffen liebe
freunde arbeiten wir tag für tag
wir schaffen damit in diesem land eine
heilsame unruhe und das gelingt uns
wirklich exzellent ich will mir lieber
gar nicht vorstellen was in diesem land
erst los wäre wenn die afg nicht als
politisch höchst erfolgreiches korrektiv
wirken würde
dass die hier schon viel zu lange
regierenden zu korrekturen zwingt die
sie von sich aus garantiert niemals
vornehmen
lassen sie sich lassen sie sich aber
bitte von den ganzen wolkigen
absichtserklärungen die ständig von der
csu insbesondere von der verbreitet
werden und die nun auch auf dem eu rats
gibt für den brüssel einzug hielten
nicht täuschen
das passiert da nichts außer dass man
nur wortreich bekundet nun endlich das
tun zu wollen was wir die afd
von anbeginn der krise anfordern das ist
witzig werden fordern das was die da
jetzt in brüssel vorgeben tun zu wollen
als vage absichtsbekundung seit drei
jahren und was sind wir dafür
verunglimpft wurden mittlerweile ist das
dann das ergebnis eines brüsseler war
brüsseler gipfels rein verbal natürlich
machen wäre das nämlich nicht immer
daran denken nicht an ihren worten an
ihren taten sollt ihr sie messen
meine damen und herren die sinistren die
sinistren ideologen des
multikulturalismus und der systematisch
betriebenen auflösung von staatsgrenzen
haben namen
ich erspare mir die hier zu nennen jeder
kann sie sich denken
es sind übrigens mensch das hält mir auf
die ganz überwiegend kinderlos sind
es sind oft menschen die weder zu eigen
liebe fähig sind noch zur nächstenliebe
noch zu wirklicher nicht geheuchelt
empathie und wer dabei an die kanzlerin
denken kann ich das nicht absprechen
diese mensch diese menschen und die frau
ist ja nicht allein diese menschen
halten sich für eine intellektuelle
intellektuelle avantgarde des kommenden
strikt multikulturellen europa und wer
sich ihnen in den weg stellt wird von
ihnen wir alle kennen das als verbohrt
ewiggestrig reaktionärer rechtsextrem
verunglimpft sie leiten ihre politische
daseinsberechtigung aus ihrer ideologie
ab und meinen dafür müssen auch opfer
hingenommen werden
auch diese opfer haben nahmen sie heißen
in unserem land zum beispiel maria mia
oder susanne um nur drei unendlich
traurige fälle zu nennen sie werden
beweint von ihren nächsten die den
verlust ihrer liebsten wie auch nicht
verwinden können
für die apologeten in boras ideologie
ist dass der vermeintlich höheren ziele
will wegen hinzunehmen und natürlich
weisen sie wie immer jede verantwortung
spricht von sich
liebe freunde an dieser ideologie ist
wie schon bei den ganzen tief inhuman
fürchterlichen und oft tödlichen ismen
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts praktisch
alles falsch und diese leute sind vor
allem auch keineswegs die intellektuelle
avantgarde für die sie sich halten
ganz im gegenteil die zeit geht über sie
hinweg noch eine kurze weile mögen sie
hier mit ihrem ganzen faulen tricks die
geschicke bestimmen
aber ich sage deren politisches ende ist
nah der multikulturalismus
wir können das sehen überall in europa
wir haben die vorboten überall der
multikulturalismus ist der ideologische
grund irrtum des frühen 21
jahrhunderts und wer genau hinsieht
erkennt bereits wie die zeit über diese
weltfremde ideologie und utopie
hinweggeht liebe freunde jede
veränderung jede große veränderung nimmt
immer ihren anfang in den köpfen der
menschen und sie nimmt ihren
unaufhaltsamen verlauf dann wenn eine
kritische menge an menschen eine
kritische menge an zumutung an löwen an
offenkundiger manipulation nicht mehr zu
ertragen bereit ist dann wenn die dinge
offenkundig anders sind als die von der
staatsführung und ihnen ergebenen medien
war sein tag für tag verkauft werden
dass die menschen ihre permanente
entmündigung nicht mehr hinzunehmen
bereit sind und der apparat sich seine
eigenen märchen nicht mehr glaubt dann
ist es zeit für veränderung und da sind
wir
wer wüsste wer wüsste das besser als die
menschen im osten unseres landes die die
großen veränderungen der wende 1989
mutig und furchtlos herbeigeführt haben
damals wurde der verlogenen narrativ des
real existierenden sozialismus von ihnen
hinweggefegt an uns ist es nun den
ebenso verlorene narrativ des
buchstäblich grenzenlosen
multikulturalismus ebenso hinwegzufegen
und genau das werden wir tun und wir
lassen uns da nicht aufhalten
wir haben damit bereits begonnen und
manchen geht es so langsam ich sage wir
kommen gut voran es braucht ein stück
geduld wir werden vielleicht noch eine
weile brauchen aber wir kommen gut voran
in einem einzigen punkt das mag
erstaunen gebe ich angela merkel recht
ja ich weiß das kann kann hier nur
verblüffende hervorruft mich ja selbst
aber von 99 dinge die falsch muss man
kann nur eine richtig sein
ich bin nämlich der meinung wir brauchen
dazu europa wir schaffen das nicht ganz
alleine
obwohl wir durchaus auch darin schon
wieder von merkel nicht unterscheiden
auch zu nationalen alleingängen
selbstverständlich bereit sein müssen
wenn die lage es erfordert und
derzeitigen lage ist das notwendig aber
grundsätzlich brauchen wir eine politik
mit starken verbündeten in europa die
heißen aber ganz sicherlich nicht wie
angela merkel das glaubt jean claude
juncker oder emanuele marken oder
neuerdings auch pedro sánchez
ich sage es klar diese herren sind nicht
unsere verbündeten
darüber haben wir diesen leuten mit
diesen leuten junker & co geht europa
nur seinen alten weg und seinen alten
narrativ weiter und es wird daran kaputt
gehen wenn wir dabei bleibt dieser weg
führt unweigerlich in den schleichenden
selbstmord europas die mit denen wir
zusammenarbeiten wollen müssen und mit
denen das auch geht die haben ganz
andere namen die heißen zb heinz
christian strache sebastian kurz matteo
salvini und auch viktor orban
das sind das sind unsere verbündeten
liebe freundin denn die haben wir die
zeichen der zeit erkannt und die anderen
haben das nicht und die liste ließe sich
fortsetzen
ich konnte dem so manchen weniger
bekannten namen von dem man sicherlich
noch viel hören wird hinzufügen mit
diesen mitstreitern können wir das neue
das vitale und zukunftsfähige europa
bauen diese mitstreiter wissen wie wir
dass es eine festung europa braucht wenn
wir nicht untergehen wollen in diesem
jahrhundert ja wohl eine festung europa
darunter geht das nicht
um unsere werte unsere zivilisation
unserer geschichte und unsere kultur zu
bewahren
in ungarn in österreich und neuerdings
auch in italien ist man da bereits einen
ganz wichtigen schritt weiter als hier
bei uns in deutschland
dort hat die notwendige politische
umsetzung bereits eingesetzt die auch
wir brauchen und die wir in naher
zukunft ich bin absolut zuversichtlich
ich habe diesen pessimismus anderer
leute nicht auch hier hinbekommen werden
freilich und ganz sicher ohne frau
merkel und ihre ganzen günstlinge das
alte ist immer noch nicht weg ich sagte
das alte
um missverständnissen vorzubeugen das
alte ist also immer noch nicht weg aber
es verschwindet gerade und das neue
entsteht mit steigender geschwindigkeit
liebe freunde ich schließe meine
ausführungen die afd gehört zu
deutschland wir sind da im bundestag in
bislang 14 ab oktober dann den 16
länderparlamenten und zwar mit deutlich
zweistelligen ergebnissen da bin ich mir
absolut sicher wie zweistellig werden
wir sehen aber dass wir etwas werden
liebe freunde im europaparlament und
ganz wichtig zunehmend auch auf der
kommunalen ebene
deutschland braucht die alternative für
deutschland mehr denn je denn nur mit
uns werden endlich auch in deutschland
die zwingend notwendigen veränderungen
einzug halten mit denen exemplarische
herausgegriffen österreich und ungarn
längst begonnen haben damit auch unser
schönes unser einziges unser
einzigartiges land deutschland die gute
zukunft deutschland hat die jetzt
verdient vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit und die geduld es musste
diesmal etwas länger dauern
viele der programmatischen ausführungen
dankeschön
da kann auch mal aufregen
[Applaus]